hi everyone welcome to our daily
homeroom livestream for those of you who
are wondering what this is this is
something we started a few months ago
it's really just a way to stay connected
have interesting conversations about
education and other topics and I'm super
excited about today's conversation I
just had to macadamia nut so I may get
Rick some water before I go sorry about
that there was a lot of water in there
that's why I had to kind of lift it up
by but before I jump into our
conversation with Jonathan Haidt I'll
get my standard announcement reminder
that kind of kind of me is a
not-for-profit we can only exist because
of philanthropic donations your position
to do so please think about it and a
special thanks to several corporations
who stepped up in the last couple of
months to allow us to accelerate our
response to cope and we were running at
a deficit even before cope it in that
deficit has only grown special thanks to
Bank for America google.org AT&T fastly
and Novartis and we're still running at
a deficit so any help either as an
individual or corporation or our
foundation is much appreciated so with
that I'm excited to introduce Jonathan
Jonathan we've seen each other at
several conferences we even have some
funders in common thanks for joining us
my pleasure Sal and let me also just say
thank you for all you're doing for us
parents during quarantine my my wife and
I were pressuring my son to pick
something pick something to learn so he
went to Khan Academy and he's taking
your JavaScript course thank you well we
are honored to be of service and for
everyone listening we're going to be
taking questions for Jonathan and myself
if you're interested so please put the
comments on YouTube or Facebook wherever
you're watching and we have team members
who will surface it but Jonathan you you
have a fascinating job area of research
you are a social psychologist focused on
the psychology of morality what is that
and that'll help people start thinking a
question to do sure okay well so
morality refers to the fact that we're
always judging each other we don't just
live in a physical world we live in a
world made of norm
and expectations and those keep us in
line they give us endless things to talk
about gossip about they lead to conflict
endless conflict but morality also makes
possible cooperation we're an amazingly
cooperative species the Oh bees are more
cooperative than us but you know not a
lot of other creatures so cooperation
and conflict that's a lot of what I
study and that has brought me into the
study of politics in particular I used
to look at how how morality varied
across cultures and beginning as the
cultural war began to heat up in the in
the United States in the 1990s and early
2000s I began to look at how left and
right are like different countries yeah
I definitely want to talk about that I'm
sure there's going to be questions about
it you know when you look at your your
your three publications you know kind of
common everyday reader publications
outside of academics you know you you
have three books a one is the happiness
hypothesis finding modern truths and
ancient wisdom I'd love you know your
big takeaways there and I'm curious how
it's affected your life your other one
is the righteous mind why good people
are divided by politics and religion and
then most recently the coddling of the
American mind how good intentions and
bad ideas are setting up a generation
for failure and so that will also help
prompt people to think about what
questions to ask
but I mean let's just go in order you
know from the happiness hypothesis this
is something I spend a lot of time
thinking about about how to optimize not
only my own life but how to optimize
generally Society so that we can be
happier what are kind of your takeaways
I mean how has it affected your personal
life when you did this research with
them sure so yeah but the book is it
grows out of my course at the University
of Virginia I taught there for 17 years
and and I would try to present
psychological insights to students and I
would often use quotes from the ancients
east and west and I found that there's
you know small number of ideas that have
been discovered in almost every society
you know like there's nothing good or
bad but thinking makes it so
that Shakespeare said you know that's
the basis of cognitive therapy so I
wrote a book one one truth in each
chapter and I reviewed what's the modern
research on it and the book wasn't
supposed to be about
happiness but it turns out that if you
take a lot of ancient wisdom there are a
lot of connecting threads on how to live
a good life how to flourish and I'll
save you all the trouble of buying the
book calls I'll summarize thousands of
years and a a couple of sentences when
it comes down to is happiness doesn't
come from getting what you want okay
that's very short lived it happiness
comes from within more so that's better
but really the best way to to summarize
the human condition is that happiness
comes from between that is friendly it
comes from getting the right kinds of
relationships between yourself and
others yourself and your work some sort
of productive work and yourself in
something larger than yourself being
having a sense that your life matters
you're part of something bigger and if
you get those three conditions right
you're gonna be about as happy as you
can be so we all have a kind of a
setpoint a general level of happiness
that we return to but if you get those
three those three conditions right
you'll sort of be you know generally
above that you know at the high end of
that range so there you go the secrets
are happiness trust me it's a lot more
interesting when you go through it
slowly I shouldn't just cut to the chase
and giving you the answer no I think
IIIi have the book and then I I
encourage everyone to go through it but
there's a lot that you know I talk a lot
about on this about my own journeys you
know and meditation but I do and we also
talk about how important it is to have a
purpose and feel like you're you know
contributing to something larger and so
that definitely reinforces my my
existing beliefs and and as you also
write about confirmation bias it's a
very connection that's right it's always
it always feels good to be proven right
it's and then related to that I think
that gets into you know a lot of what
you've been focused on lately including
with your with your not-for-profit which
is you know it's clear that there's
significant polarization politics is by
definition always somewhat polarizing
but there is a scent and you probably
have evidence that it is unusually
polarized right now I love your well um
if you have any evidence that it is
truly it's not just an intuitive sense
but it is you know measurably unusually
polarized right now and also what do you
think are the sociological con
reasoned and then maybe we could go into
how do we how do we depolarize or if we
should sure okay so you know so as you
said politics is is by nature polarizing
you have parties that represent groups
of interests or identities or whatever
and then they compete and elections are
zero-sum so there's nothing wrong with
that and even some degree of
polarization like peoples are far apart
on views it's not necessarily bad but
think of it this way suppose you have a
sports league in which you know the
Yankees and the Red Sox hate each other
just you know theoretically that could
actually make the game more fun but
suppose they hate each other so much
that they start hiring hitman to kill
members of the other team and they do
things to sabotage the field okay now
you're like you're totally out of bounds
like this is not what the game is
okay now let's turn to American politics
so there's some debate among political
scientists about what polarization means
and if you think about like views on hat
on policy issues like abortion by some
measures were not more polarized than we
were as a psychologist I focus on one
thing and one thing alone that is
effective polarization which means
emotional how much do you feel emotion
negative to you hate the other side
that's what's crucial and the data shows
very clearly that in the 70s and 80s and
even into the 90s Republicans and
Democrats they rated the people on the
other side or the parties on the other
side so a little you know a little
negative but not not at the bottom and
it begin the the ratings we get to get
extremely negative and the late nineties
is when it begins and then it goes down
and down and down there is such hatred
now that this has a lot of ramifications
one of which is we are now really
willing to believe almost anything if
you hate the other side you're much more
willing to believe crazy stuff about
them so that's one whole piece is rising
polarization and then let's add in the
change in social media and in cable TV t
so we now have a media ecosystem that is
really well designed to find the most
anger provoking outrageous stuff it can
be totalized but it's gonna funnel it in
and so for a lot of reasons we're now
you know we're in a democracy which has
to have
public square which ideas are hashed out
and we generally make progress we
improve ideas that when sometimes
there's compromise I mean that's what we
need to do to live in a democracy and I
think it's much harder to do that now
than it was even ten years ago to say
nothing of 20 or 30 years ago I what do
you think it was in the 90s and then it
sounds like it accelerated in the last
20 years that that caused this I guess
you could say the amplification of
polarization or yes judgement is gonna
be yes yeah so you know our minds like
to look for a thing that happens like if
you know because you see the curves they
really do begin to dip in the 90s and
you might say oh well you know it must
have been you know Newt Gingrich or Fox
News as if that's what you would say if
you're on the Left it's from the point
to that if you're on the right I imagine
you point to to Bill Clinton so but what
I like to do is is these are complex
systems that have a lot of parameters to
them and I like to think what are the
forces that were kind of pulling any
complex system together what are the
force that are blowing it apart and a
lot of them began changing in the around
this time so what for one thing we have
to see the late 20th century as an
historical anomaly when democracy our
democracy had lots of problems but we
thought democracy was ultimately the way
that everyone was gonna live once the
Soviet Union imploded we thought wow you
know liberal democracy with free-market
capitalism like this is you know at the
end of history everyone's gonna go this
way but we didn't realize is that
democracy is actually really really hard
and the founding fathers and the
Federalist Papers they really worried
about our tendency to faction to split
up slit apart and hate the other side so
I just went to a couple of factors one
is the loss of a common enemy so you
know from Pearl Harbor in World War two
through the Cold War having a common
enemy really binds a group together so
that's a big one another really big one
is the media environment after World War
two we had three television networks
that had a Fairness Doctrine so they had
a they couldn't be very political so for
a while we had a media system in which
we kind of all got the same sort of news
and then once you get cable TV and then
the internet and
and social media now you go from
broadcasting to everyone so that we all
hear the same stuff to narrowcasting and
of course people using Facebook data and
advertising data that you know really
micro-target so it's we're not on the
same page we don't believe the same
things we're in a state of moral and
factual incoherence and we may be that
way for the rest of our lives so those
are a couple of big ones but there are
there are many others that began
changing and the result is hatred
distrust distrust of each other and
distrust of institutions has been rising
steadily to the point where it's I think
extremely dangerous it's really not
clear what's going to happen to our
country I know you're out in the big
business of predicting but what do you
think is what do you think is a natural
extrapolation from where we are right
now if you go out five or ten years no
boy um the well put it this way if
current trends continue then our country
would probably fall apart in a
catastrophic way but please don't quote
me I know people watching live because
if current trends continue then I think
we'll be in big trouble but the thing is
current trends never continue this
really it will continue forever and if
you zoom out if you take the big picture
and you look at both human history in
which life is getting better you know
rights are being extended science
advances knowledge at you the big
picture life is getting better and
better and there are you know there are
dips but but then it keeps rising Steve
Pinker has books like the better angels
of our nature there are a variety of
books that have really tried to
encourage us to realize in every age
people think things are terrible when
they're going to hell but actually
things are generally getting better so
it's always been wrong to bet against
America and you know I think in China
and a few other countries they are
enjoying our mess you know for
geostrategic reasons odds are we'll
figure a way out of this so I my short
answer is I can't predict I think their
variety scenarios in which things look
even even scarier and weirder you know
in the
next year and next year or two but we're
likely to find ways out of this we have
to solve a lot of problems we've got to
improve so many things about our
democracy the way we vote the the sense
that people have a voice you know
gerrymandering there's there's all these
problems with our democracy and I do
hope that you know things change
politically next year that democracy
reform and improvement will be very high
on the agenda yeah and you know you talk
about the importance I guess of a common
enemy to hold people a little bit closer
together and obviously we are facing
something of a common enemy and the
pandemic and from YouTube is shawni
tarkir asked do you think well there's
more of epidemiological question do you
think it'll have a second wave and it
sounds like it already is but if we do
how do you think it'll affect society
will it cause Democrats and Republicans
have a greater divide or will they
finally come come together yes so let's
back up and go back to those halcyon
early days of the pandemic when we were
all trying to come to grips it was
inconceivable that we'd have to shut
everything down and stay home for months
inconceivable and as we came to grips
with it as that happened it was like oh
my god everyone is doing this you know
this is a global thing and in those
first weeks that was the big question
people were asking is this gonna bring
us together but let's step back here and
understand what happens to societies
when you have an a foreign attack that
brings people together when you have a
pandemic in history that divides people
apart if we have a disease coming in
people are afraid of each other there
are shortages so pandemics traditionally
have actually split people apart now
this pandemic is different because we
didn't have food shortages it wasn't
that deadly like like the plague I mean
it wasn't like you know half the people
were going to die
and it was an amazing shared experience
so in the early days the polling showed
many more people were saying we're all
in this together but here's the amazing
and messed-up and tragic thing about our
country our culture war is so severe
that within it took about four or five
weeks by mid April the pandemic itself
had divided the country now I think a
lot of that can be laid directly at the
foot of the
president who was tweeting you know
liberate Virginia and things like that
so the the both of the the president the
media environment within a few weeks we
had a left-right divide over wearing
masks over the speed of opening up over
so many other things so I don't think
that the pandemic will help or bring us
together at a national level now locally
lots of great stuff happens so you know
you got a look at multiple levels but
overall America has handled this
pandemic horrific ly incompetently and
of course you can blame many actors and
agencies but a portion of the story is
our polarization we don't trust each
other or the authorities yeah and it
related to this or maybe not I mean you
tell me you know your most recent book
the coddling of the American mind has
this played into this polarization has a
polarization played into that or is that
just another you know orthogonal
dimension to what's going on inside yeah
well so yeah so briefly the so the
cognitive American mind is about the big
changes that we began to see on campus
and in high schools as gen Z came in Gen
Z people born 1996 or 1997 depending on
how you count it but around then mid 90s
their childhoods are different from the
Millennials and their mental health
profiles are different they have much
higher rates of anxiety in depression
nothing else really just anxiety and
depression and as well-documented oh yes
very well document yes if you go to the
coddling calm summer on the front page I
have a link to a giant Google Doc where
I've I've collected all the studies
showing you know on any side as to is it
is it rising and then a second document
is social media a part of the cause and
you know when we started this where this
is originally the insight was from Greg
lukianov when we started this with an
Atlanta Carl in 2015 everyone on campus
campuses across the country were talking
about the rise of mental health needs
but we didn't have any hard data on it
and by 2016 2017 now all the survey data
was showing this is real and it's not
just self-report it's not just that Gen
Z is comfortable talking about it
because you find the same increase
for self-harm and you find a similar
increase on suicide so this is behavior
it's not just changes in diagnostic
criteria so we're trying to understand
why that is and it is that a portion of
it especially the sex difference may be
or seems to be due in part to the effect
of social media especially on middle
school kids social media really changes
around 2011-2012 in that in that they're
20 2009 to 2012 but the other piece is
the vast overprotection that Americans
put on kids that it happened in Canada
Britain too we stopped letting them out
to play as much we got really scared
about them deduction and we over
protected kids and what kids most need
to grow socially as free play
unsupervised free play where they get in
conflicts they work things out
themselves so for so that's what that
book is about and no I don't think
doesn't tell us much about the pandemic
but it did but yes we should definitely
talk about it for as an educational
nonprofit I don't know if you saw are
you seeing any signs of this I mean you
know your audience is almost office
mostly I would guess Gen Z are you
seeing signs that gen Z is different
from from Millennials or old previous
generations well you know the very
nature of Khan Academy we are you know
removed physically so we're only
engaging in you know kind of through the
exercises or the videos that they might
might watch so we don't see it as
directly there's other you know kind of
non Khan Academy outlets where at least
as a know I hate to admit it but that
was a middle-aged person I'm like oh
these young and foul yeah you know and I
wonder whether this is just something
that every you know generation goes
through you know once all of a sudden
you turn 40 and all of a sudden you you
think you're not that different than a
25 year old but you realize that
cultural difference or maybe they're
just like I was when I was 25 I'm
different now and I'm 40 yeah ya know
know each you know it's true that each
generation thinks the one behind it is
you know lazy you know every generation
criticizes the one behind it and often
the criticisms are the same across
thousands of years so you're right to
wonder that but if you look at the
mental health data something really
happened around 2012 is when the lines
began going way way up for girl
and not as much but up still also for
boys so these are these are objective
measures of mental health in terms of
those that are behavioral so it is the
other thing I can say is you have spoken
about the book at many high schools and
universities to Gen Z audiences and it
was a tie
you know I lay out the case here's what
we think is happening and I was asked
them do you think this is right or you
know or you know I just said something
you know painted your generation in a
certain way and overwhelmingly they say
it's it's it's a correct portrait
because they recognize they recognize
the effects of overprotection
and of being on social media so heavily
Gen Z is not in denial they you know
what I've seen is they generally want a
broader range of experience they want to
be exposed to ideas they want to grow up
to be stronger and successful and so you
have these two factors you know this
notion of social media finish I
understand that these would have been
kids who are essentially at entering
adolescence around 2012-2013 races right
when obviously I mean social media had
already started to gain momentum but
around 2012 2013 it became huge you know
your your Facebook's your instagrams
snapchats of of the world and what do
you think is this you know how does
social media connect and there's a
question if I can still find it or where
someone was asking of YouTube you know
do you think that there's is it a net
negative that social media or or or the
you know are there kind of from bouncing
influences sure so so yeah the important
thing that people need to understand
about it's about social media is that it
really changed in two years so it comes
out you get you know myspace and friends
during the Facebook around 2004 and it's
you know Here I am here's my picture
here are the bands I like here you know
my links to my various friends
that's not toxic that's not bad for
anyone's mental health in 2009 Facebook
Ads the like button and Twitter ads the
retweet button and now there's a huge
amount of information on engagements and
everybody is reinforcing everybody else
it's almost like a like an operon
experiment you know with you know uh
James above them anyway that you know
the behaviorist conditioning experiments
and so you have so much engagement data
now the platforms use that to algorithm
size what they feed and so now social
media becomes much more addictive it
lures many more people in and it creates
an outrage machine that is now it's very
easy to drop something in spreads and so
by 2012 the meat environment is
different now the newspapers the
old-line media has to play the game
advertising shifts onto Facebook by 2014
this thing is so powerful that the
Russians who've been messing with our
democracy since the mid 20th century the
Russians activate all their networks to
make us even more angry at each other
and put in a lot of lies and a lot of
manipulation a lot of fake sites so 2014
now it's like we've got this you know
we're large we're public squares this
outrage machine being directly
manipulated by other countries and by
bad actors within this country and so I
think that's when 2014-2015 is when our
politics really felt like it was going
haywire and this I believe is made
possible an opening for Donald Trump who
I don't think could have been elected in
a normal election year but he was very
he was very skilled at using this this
free media so it's when I make the point
people have to understand it's not just
like you know being on social media it's
being a mesh in this stream of constant
judgement and outrage and it's
exhausting and it's especially bad for I
believe for middle school kids so I I'm
not taking the position on whether
adults should use it but I think 11 12
13 year-olds really should not be on it
they certainly should not be on it
without the permission of their parents
but at present anyone can sign up for an
account there's no verification and you
see that you see kids get sucked into
this and there it you know that the
chronic anxiety of being judged about
kahan flicks high cortisol levels
extended over you know days weeks months
is bad for development and this is
really interesting because you know just
as an observer I think a lot of people
will say oh yes social media it makes
you insecure maybe anxious because you
see other people's best lies they're
going on the case
perfect they look perfect in the morning
as 10 etcetera and then you feel
insecure about your very real life
you're saying they maybe that's part of
it but you're saying it's something a
little bit different is that it's
reinforcing views in a bubble and
allowing to feel kind of moral outrage
about another and the other is not even
in your bubble so they're not even in a
position to defend themselves and so
that causes the anxiety because you're
just looking at you're like I can't
believe there's half the the country or
half the world that is that crazy that
they're after me they're after people I
care about
yeah well not exactly me separate two
different things there's the there's the
mental health effects which seemed to be
especially prominent in in early
adolescence and especially in girls so
when when social life went from lots of
face to face getting together your
friends to doing it online where there's
constant judgment and anything can can
explode that I think is particularly bad
for teen mental health that's one piece
of it
then there's the democracy piece which
is not about kids and it's not about
anxiety it's about anger and and the
ability to find truth and so that is a
part of the reason I think that our
democracy is going haywire and why we're
seeing some similar movements in many
Western countries there's all kinds of
economic causes - I don't oversimplify
but you know I'm a I was born in 1963
I'm a product for the twentieth century
you know my generation we were raised to
believe democracy is the greatest thing
it conquered it was better than all
other systems and if you're born in 1996
and all you've seen is the 21st century
you know it's not so clear that
democracy is this great thing I'm not
saying it's not I'm just saying it's not
working that well these days and it's
not just an America then it's happening
and I think social media is a part of it
it's not it's not most of it but it is a
it is an accelerant it it just makes
it's exactly what the Founding Fathers
feared that faction and conflict will
spread like wildfire and so what and
these are two fascinating threads that
are probably related to it as a mental
health read what's healthy for young
kids and then what that may be doing you
know broadly to a generation maybe if
that's playing a role in our
polarization you know there's several
questions here I just thought I'm
there's so many questions I'm having
scrolling but there's a question about
you know what recommendation would you
have for parent of adolescent you take
them off a social media you yeah so they
don't care yeah so you know the easy
thing would be to say don't let your kid
have social media until they're 16 or 18
that would be you know an easy thing to
say but it wouldn't it wouldn't work so
so the first thing is to differentiate
between screen time and social media so
it's not screens per se that are bad so
spending time on Khan Academy but of
course you should get some exercise
during the day but you know spending
hours learning coding is not bad for you
in any way that's you know so it's not
screens it's specifically social media
where you're making content and then
you're looking who said what about it
you know what are people thinking so
it's specifically social media and the
effects seem biggest on younger
adolescents so my advice okay and then
the third thing to add in here is we're
we're all trapped in a game we're all
trapped in a situation in which you know
when I told my son when he started sixth
grade that he couldn't have Instagram he
said but almost everyone else in my
class has it so it was harder for my son
very few people wanted their kids on but
we're all trapped every parent says well
okay if everybody else is on it I'll let
you on it so I think we have to have
leadership from middle school principals
we have to have leadership parents have
to get together we have to have a common
agreement to keep kids off of social
media at least until high school I think
that that's the the clearest thing is it
should not be in middle schools kids
should have a it's hard enough to be in
middle school with all the gossip and
all the all the changes and all the
growth and all the embarrassment get it
out of middle school I think we would
then see these these the rates of
anxiety and depression I think they
would come down somewhat yeah I would
just say also not for parents I think
it's also important to talk with your
kids about what kind of childhood they
want because as far as I found Gen Z is
actually pretty reasonable and they they
you know they don't want to spend their
whole lives on online and so helping
them set limits because you've got all
these psychologists in Silicon Valley
working so that if you give your kid a
device they'll stay on it so this makes
no sense to give your child's time over
to this psychologist in Silicon Valley
you and your child should decide and
then use the Apple screen time controls
or whatever I think those work very well
and also agree at a time that device has
come out of the bedroom that I think is
very very important otherwise kids get
sucked in at night they they're they're
doing it in a jiffy with sleep it just
go on forever do you really hire
psychologists at social media companies
to come I just drive the addiction
factor opera though absolutely oh my
goodness yes let me the psychology of
slot machines the psychology of
engagement oh yes they hire a lot of
psychologists there's a lab at Stanford
that trained a lot of a lot of designers
in how do you hook people how do you
keep them on your product yes yeah we do
a little bit of work obviously we think
we're doing it for a good purpose for
her you know how do you hook someone on
to learning or engagement but that's you
know we don't have a team of you know
cognitive scientists but well it's so if
your goal is to help them finish a
lesson and reach a goal that they
themselves endorse then that's just good
psychology there's there's you know I'm
sure you have all kinds of points and
rewards built in that's that's good
psychology it's when you're trying to
undercut their own resolutions and try
to keep them on even longer than they'd
like to be on so if you look at the
regret factor how much are you how happy
are you at the time that you spend on
Khan Academy
I would guess excuse me hello say hello
to the live audience okay so you know I
would guess that if you if you ask if
you ask kids how happy are you with the
time do you wish you spend if you feel
if you spend too much time on Khan
Academy well okay if the parents are
forcing them maybe they'll say it's too
much but if it's if it's self-driven
they'd be happy with it yeah no I mean
these conversations I we could talk for
several hours and hopefully we can we
can have you back on because each of
these threads I think we can double and
triple and quadruple click on maybe just
to kind of finish up maybe on a positive
note you know I know you're above and
beyond your academic research and your
writing you're involved in you know
trying to change maybe at least not only
observe but maybe depolarize Society we
had the question from Facebook Kathy
Gifford Vance
positive actions can individuals take to
mitigate some of the negative impact of
increasing polarization well yeah well
what should we do collectively or no
Julie oh good thank you thank you Kathy
for that for that question so a lot of
the big changes are going to be systemic
changes in you know elections and media
and all sorts of things but all of us as
individuals all of us are caught up in a
system that makes us hyper moralize and
so to go back to the happiness i pathes
is one of the you know one of the great
truths is that we're too judgmental is
that here let me see actually I actually
have some some quotes here let's see so
this is something you hear from all over
you know judge not lest ye be judged
Buddha says hatred never ends through
hatred by love alone does it end sense
on says when love and hate are both
absent everything becomes clear and
undisguised make the smallest
distinction in heaven and earth are so
infinitely far apart we are so
judgmental and we also have the capacity
to understand people and when we do that
we lose some of our anger and we can
talk to them so what I would recommend
is everybody realize we're caught up in
endless streams of outrage and you as an
individual can step out of it can reach
out to people can try to understand them
I recommend especially the book how to
win friends and influence people by Dale
Carnegie it'll give you almost a social
superpower you have the capacity to
actually persuade people to actually
connect with people and social media
pulls us into this conflict mindset but
you'll be much more successful in life
if you try to understand people persuade
them and learn to work with them at very
least it'll help you in your own
marriage and with your own children and
really that I I know we're already over
time there's another really good
question it also will help typo on this
you know there's a question from
Facebook John Hepworth is there a way to
detoxify social media you know you're
having these debates I know Facebook is
struggling do you take off certain
certain posts and even if it they're
from the president or not and there's
really kind of a no-win situation you're
gonna make someone
that you know and then there's free
speech rights but then it's you know
there's all these things what would you
do if you were if you were Mark
Zuckerberg would you edit speech when
you change the platformers mostly to
make it less beep toxic as a detoxifier
yes I think yes I think it's essential
that we make the platform's less toxic
there was a report and the Wall Street
Journal of a month ago about how
Facebook had they had studied
polarization they had thought about ways
to reduce the degree to which it is
exposed and they dropped it so I think
Facebook there's a lot of responsibility
here there's a lot more that they could
be doing twitter has hardly any social
psychologists on its staff I think
Twitter needs to really start studying
these issues they've taken a couple of
steps here and there I have an article
in the Atlantic but Tobias rose
Stockwell into it within last November
in which we laid out a few steps that
could be taken that could be done one is
to add friction here and there when
you're about to post something that
seems to be particularly aggressive or
toxic between that little bits of
friction but that's a small thing more
algorithm accountability the algorithm
oast people are pretty reasonable this
is wherever I go most people are pretty
reasonable but the algorithms give much
more voice to the people at the extremes
that people are not reasonable cuz they
generate engagement we need to
understand those algorithms and there
needs to be some public comment on them
some way to change the algorithms I
think the biggest bang is gonna come
when we find ways not to have to go
after each individual post but to reward
users who are civil and show some nuance
and some constructiveness and so you
know if I could you know if I could you
know mark the people who I think are
particularly the great or no not me
marking if if there were ways to code
for integrative complexity or civility
or constructiveness if the platforms
could code for things so that I could
set you know what I don't want anybody
who scores zero I don't want trolls who
just you know their content is very
predictable I want to cut them out so
that they don't see me I don't see them
we would all have a much much better
life on social media so I think this is
one of the trends if this keeps going on
I think our public square our ability to
talk to each other is in big trouble I
think we're gonna have to have major
reforms to social media that makes it
less nasty
less conspiracy generating let's don't
reach generating and you know one
question and I know I keep asking
questions for over time but I mean it
sounds like some of these reforms would
just be bad business for it for these
come because obviously it's oftentimes
the more extreme statement the things
that are generating outrage that get you
sucked in that make you want to comment
that make you click on something and
it's not that social media as you
mentioned our mainstream media or your
TV media or prep are pretty the airline
there's also polar they've also
discovered this business model that's
right yes as many have commented you
know the business model is such that we
are not the customers it's the
advertisers who are the customers you
know where the tuna fish that gets
hooked on the other hook and you know
deliver to the customers in a sense
so yes the business model will have to
change ultimately from but I would put
it this way so I teach a course at NYU
Stern on professional responsibilities
it's our ethics course and one of the
things that becomes clear when you look
at all these cases is that in the short
run cheating often pays but in the long
run ethics generally does pay and so you
know in the long run if people really
hate Facebook and the more you know
we're seeing that this month boycotts
can be extremely costly and if there's
all kinds of people in a boycott
something well if someone comes up with
a better product that is not as tough
that is does not lead to such toxicity
people know them though Facebook would
lose market share so in the in the in
the long run I think ethics pays and
also most of the you know the people I
met in Silicon Valley
it's full of idealistic people who you
know who really think we're want to
believe that they're making the world
better so I am hopeful that some big
changes will happen but big changes have
to happen yeah well Jonathan you've
given us so much to think about I
encourage everyone to take a look at all
of Jonathan's writing it with it but he
said the coddling calm you go to the
coddling calm yeah you can get to
everywhere else for them from there to
get some more data but but Jonathan
thank you so much this was extremely
insightful and it give me a lot to think
about
great my pleasure self thanks for all
that you and your team do to educate the
world
appreciate it so
thanks everyone for joining as always
these conversations I don't know why you
know I enter into them saying oh yeah I
got maybe 10 minutes worth of questions
than we realized 40 minutes go by so
thanks for joining as you saw Johnson
fascinating his research I could spend
several hours on every one of those
topics we talked about but thanks for
joining this week and I think we're off
to well actually I'm not going to say
that I think we're off tomorrow but we
will see but I will see you at the next
live stream see you then